that all share commonality
These chapters seem arbitrary
For the untrained eye from
Zedenmat. As a matter of fact,
every book written by man, pros
and has cons, has pros and has
shortcomings. Things that could
have been better, could have
been done better, right? It is
only Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala's book that is perfect.
It could not be perfected more,
right? And Zad Al Maad, one of
the One of the points that some
of the scholars have made with
regards to Zad Al Maed that
this book could have been done
better is the order of the
chapters. They seem arbitrary.
They'll discuss one thing and
then he'll discuss the rest of
that thing. Many many pages
later. And it seems because
honestly that is how he wrote
it. He wrote it from his memory
as he was traveling. And he
said in the introduction I'm
writing this book, Away From My
Library and Traveling. My
thoughts are scattered and my
books are not with me, right?
So, he wrote it as it came to
mind. So, some scholars have
actually taken this book Zad il
Maed. And they've reorganized
it. They've put all the
chapters together you
would find in a book of Filk,
right? That's interesting but
always, we to have the
original that the scholar
wrote. Right? We want to have
the original work. It's good to
have, you know, a bridged
versions. It's good to have
versions that have been worked
on and pined over by other
scholars but at the end of the
day, we do want to always have
the original work of the
scholar at hand because that is
invaluable, really. These
chapters that we are dealing
with, they seem arbitrary. They
seem random but they're not.
Because Ibn Allah, he
introduced these chapters after
we finished Hajj, right? The
five pillars of Islam. He
introduced to us chapters with
a he introduced these chapters
with a chapter regarding the
tongue and the etiquettes of
the tongue and speech. We've
discussed the principles of
those etiquettes in detail. He
started it out really by
discussing names and how names
have an effect on on the and
have an effect on the thing
that has been named, right? How
even people, their own name
will have an effect on their
destiny and have an effect on
who they identify themselves
as. But all of these chapters
now, we've discussed in the
previous chapter, in the
previous chapters we've
discussed, how he used to make
the prophet How, what he used
to say when he would enter his
home, what he would say for
Adan, and and after salah, and
during Eid. Now, we going into
the etiquettes of what he would
say and how he would conduct
himself in the presence of
food. How he would eat, what he
would say, before he eats,
after he eats, etcetera. So,
these seem arbitrary
chapters but really they are
all connected and they are all
tied together by one
overarching theme and that is
etiquettes of the tongue,
etiquettes of speech. I can't
enough. How pivotal speech is
in our lives We live in a world
currently that is overflowing
with speech, idle talk, right?
Overflowing with love. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says in the
Quran. Describing the believers
He describe the people of El
Ferdos, the highest levels of
paradise, one of their traits
is that they turn away from
level. So, what is a level? A
level in the Arabic language,
literally translates to
Twitter. I'm not joking. That's
really the literal translation
of the word level. What is
Twitter? Twitter is the sound
of birds. a level in the Arabic
language is the sound of birds
that is unintelligible. It just
fills the atmosphere. We don't
really know what they're
saying. It, right? That's what
is. If you look it up in the
dictionary, it'll say Twitter,
right? Which kind of is ironic
But the point is, is that we
live in a world that is
overflowing. Just busting at
the seams with excessive talk,
excessive actions, level. It's
overflowing with level. People
complain all the time. I don't
have time to do this. I don't
have enough time to, you know,
learn the Quran. I don't have
enough time to do this and
that. You we have plenty of
time. We have more time than we
would know what to do with it.
we are so preoccupied with the
distraction that we are under
this under this we have this
belief that we have no time
when really we have more time
allotted to us than probably
any other time in human history
I mean just just a vehicle or
an airplane saves months of
travel right people wanted to
travel we we the trip in 1
hour. Used to take three, four,
five days to get there, right?
One way. So, we have, you know,
a person wants to bathe. You
had to go to a well and draw
water and heat the water up and
bathe. Now, you just turn the
faucet and there you go. Hot
water coming down on you. You
don't even have to pour it on
yourself. Right? People wanted
to cook. They had to make fire
and they had to set it up and
get firewood and chop wood and
all these things. Now, you just
turn the gas on. We have more
time than we know what to do
with but unfortunately, our
time has been filled with
because we live in a time of so
much speech, so much talking we
start to think that our words
are meaningless. Our words
don't have the effects that
they have. Words are very
powerful. The way that you use
them may completely change the
perspective of a person
listening for good or for bad.
For positive or negative. When
you speak, when I speak, and
the more influential a person
is, the more important becomes
for them too. Be wary of their
words. Every time you
articulate something to another
human being, you are
essentially changing the way
that they look at the world.
They're never going to be the
same after whatever you've said
to them. Even if it's something
trivial, it has an effect. It
has an effect When somebody is
listening, it will have an
effect. And so, we are taught
in the Quran, in the Sunnah, to
be very of our words. The
prophet teaches us that we are
to either speak and earn merit
or we are to remain silent and
escape punishment. We are to
either speak and earn merit
right?
A person is to either speak and
gain merit or they are to
remain silent and remain safe,
remain in safety. And it's
interesting because It's almost
impossible to be too quiet We
should always speak less than
necessary, right? Because the
tongue is a monster. It can
become a monster. It is a caged
beast that is constantly
straining to break out of its
cage and run wild and cause you
grief. But we have to be very
wary of our speech. A person
who is naturally quiet,
naturally earns more respect
than a person who speaks more
than necessary. The scholars
tell us and some of the wise
men of Islamic scholarship say,
that we should remain silent as
much as possible. because
silence is an adornment for the
intelligent and it is a cover
for the for the fool. Meaning,
a person who is intelligent, if
they are silent, if they, the
more they are, the less they
speak, the more they they
become beautiful in our eyes
and the more what they say
becomes valuable. And a person
who is a fool, if he doesn't
speak, it's a cover. No one
will know a person is a fool
until he opens his mouth and
tells us. So, it's a win-win
for a person to say less than
necessary. The prophet
was asked as a what are the
things that people go to hell
for most? He said, El Femu, al
fortune. He said, the mouth and
the private parts. These are
the two things that lead people
to hell most Now, when we say
the mouth and the private
parts, we want to imagine that
these are really two categories
of sin. One being a category of
vengeance and the other being a
category of desire and passion.
These two things will lead a
person to hell. The prophet
also said,
He says, whoever guarantees to
me that he will protect and
preserve what is between his
two jaws and between his two
legs. I will guarantee for this
person paradise. Though this is
paramount for us to dwell on
speech. Speech is very
important. How you use words
has an effect. The words that
you choose to use. The emphasis
that you place on them. All of
this is very important. We've
discussed in previous chapters
how a person can overuse words
and cause them to lose value. A
person overuses words. It
causes them to use value, lose
value. What makes diamonds
precious and valuable?
Obviously, the rarity.
Likewise, gold and silver These
things are rare and because
they're rare, they're valuable.
Pearls are rare and they have a
very particular way that they
come about and you can only
bring them about in that way.
And so, they become very
valuable because of their
rarity. However, if a person
were to have if if the world
were to have too many diamonds,
they would no longer be
valuable because they are
common Likewise is the issue
with words. We can overuse
words. We can overuse words and
in doing so, we cause them to
lose value. Words such as sorry
or I apologize. How overused
are these words? Right? If they
burn your house down or if they
accidentally bump into you in
the street, it's the same word.
Sorry. Right? Sorry, I burned
your house down. Sorry, I
bumped into you, right? And in
our very superficial society,
that's you know, what we do.
Oh, sorry. Oh, excuse me.
Sorry. this kind of fake,
fake presentation of of
humility, right? sorry has no
meaning now. It has no value.
Doesn't mean anything.
Likewise, the word love. You
know, I love this. I love that.
I love. I hate this. I hate
that. I hate this movie and I
hate, you know, and I and I
hate death. It's there's
no contrast with those words.
And so, we're using the same
words to express very different
levels and intensities, those
words start to lose value and
this is why the prophet war us
about overusing words, right?
Overusing words, number one and
number 2, using words in the
wrong way, using something good
to describe someone terrible.
So, he said,
he prohibited that a hypocrite
be referred to as a Sayed, as a
person who was a you know, an
upstanding person. Say, it is
sir, you know, he
prohibited that that word be
used to describe a hypocrite.
Why? Because if we use that
word to describe good people
and bad people, the word has no
meaning anymore.
Let's take a look at the word
Sheikh. What does Sheikh mean
now? Everybody is a Sheikh. if
you have some remnants of a
beard and you talk a little
bit, you're a shirk, shirk.
Imam has no meaning. Everybody
is imam. If you studied for 40
years, your Sheikh and if you
studied for 4 days, your
Sheikh. So, the words have no
meaning anymore. What about the
word we hear this word a lot,
right? In the books of history
where we research the people
that are in the chains of
narration, very, very, rarely
will you find a scholar being
described as an Ustad. It's
almost unheard of. One who was
described as a Ustev was Ibn
Hosema, Rahima Allah the great
Muhadith. Was described as an
and that was a crown on
his head. Why? Because
traditionally among scholars
the word is only used to
describe a person who has
perfected at least 12 different
disciplines in Islamic
sciences. Hadith and Tafsir and
Luga and on and on and on. If a
person has not perfected at
least twelve then this person
is not referred to as a Usteth
Likewise, the word half of,
half of. Half of was only
traditionally used by the
scholars to describe someone
who at the bare minimum,
memorized one 000 narrations.
That is the bare minimum. If a
person has not memorized 1 000
narrations, committed them to
memory, by heart, then this
person is not considered a half
of. Now, the word half of this,
you know, thrown around for
everybody So, we see how words
can lose their value and if
these words are then used to
describe bad things, bad things
will find their way into our
lives. The prophet
mentions the narration
collected by Ibn Maja on the
authority of he says,
He said, a group from my nation
will eventually come to make
alcohol permissible,
intoxicants permissible. They
will do so by naming it by
other than its rightful name.
Right? So, we use a good name
to describe something bad. That
is the first original trick of
a Shaitan in using words.
Shaitan when he tried when he
was seducing Adam and Hawa to
eat from the forbidden tree. He
described this tree with its
opposite descriptions. He said
He described that tree that
Adam was prohibited to eat
from. He described it as the
the the tree of eternity, the
eternal tree, and a dominion
that will never perish, right?
It's exactly the opposite.
Because when they ate from that
tree, their dominion perished
and they were subject to death.
It's exactly the opposite This
is the trickery of a Shaitan.
We have to watch out for how we
use our words. Allah has
stressed this in the Quran.
He's been very precise with his
words and the prophet
throughout his life. Very
precise with his words. Used
his words very judiciously.
Says this is another sub
chapter He says
[Silence]
pain. Just bismillah, right?
and he commanded others to do
the same and if he were would
have forgotten to say Bismillah
he would say
which literally translates to,
I eat in the name of Allah at
its beginning and end. Right?
If a person goes to eat, they
begin with bismillah. If they
forget, they say, bismillah
Based on
you know, if they remember.
This is graded as an authentic
narration by it's been reported
by on the authority of Aisha.
Yes.
Start with what?
I I don't understand the
question.
[Silence]
Well, I mean, that's that's a
topic for FCF. I mean, it's
kind of kind of off topic.
so the prophet would always
start with bismillah and if
he'd forget
he says and the correct opinion
of scholars is that saying
bismillah when a person goes to
eat is obligatory. a
Meaning it is a binding. It is
obligatory upon a person. It
say bismillah. He says and the
correct opinion is that a
person who
purpos
ely does not say
bismillah than a Shaitan is his
companion in that food and
drink that he is having. He
says and the narrations that
have been mentioned and
collected of the prophet
commanding others to say
bismillah when they eat. They
are all authentic and they are
all very clear They're not
ambiguous. He said and there's
nothing authentic which
contradicts that command. And
there is no consensus amongst
the scholarship of Islam. That
dictates that It is not
obligatory to say Bisminda. So,
Ibn al Kaim here, he's
discussing with us the issue
that some people, some of the
scholars of Islam have viewed
saying bismillah as being a
sunnah, as being something
encouraged. He's saying, that
is a weak opinion, the correct
opinion is that it is
obligatory. This is also the
opinion of Sheikh Al Islam. Ibn
Tami, and that is that, a pu
who does not say bismillah when
they go to eat purposely. This
is a person who is in imitation
of a Shaitan. And he says the
least case scenario of
imitating a Shaitan purposely
is that it is haram. This is
the reasoning of Sheikh Al
Islam.
All our health
[Silence]
gather. There's a few of us and
is it enough for just one of us
to say bismillah or do we each
individually have to say
bismillah? It's a difference of
opinion. Although he does
mention that
mentions that it is permissible
and it is acceptable for just
one person to say bismillah
amongst the group. He said, and
it could be argued that a
person who does not say
bismillah. Even if someone else
in the group said bismillah,
they are still in error of
imitating a Shaitan because a
Shaitan, when he goes to eat,
he is described to us as
someone who eats with his left
hand, who does not say
bismillah. And so, If I'm
sitting in a group and one of
us says bismillah, that may be
sufficient for the barakah.
However, me not saying
bismillah, does not I I am
because one person said it and
and that is not enough for
everybody to be outside of the
realm of imitating a Shaitan or
a Shaitan being joining a
person in his meal. This is an
interesting topic. And what is
clear is that each person is
commanded to say bismillah
individually the opinion of a
is very strong and I won't get
into why that is. However, it's
not easily argued against Now,
we go back to a narration of
Omar Ibn Ebi Salema, who was
the prophet stepson, right? In
Omar, he describes to us. that
he went to eat and he was
eating in the presence of the
prophet and he was picking his
food from all over the dish.
You know, they used to eat
together in one dish and he was
kind of picking out from
wherever he wanted. The prophet
said to him,
he says, he said to me, young,
young man, say
and eat
with your right hand
only and eat
[Silence]
and a Bedouin man came and made
them seven and he started
eating with them and he seemed
to devour the dish in two quick
swipes. Two, it could have been
or five or ten but two meaning
very quickly. He finished up
the food. And the prophet
commented on this incident and
said, indeed, if he had merely
said bismillah, then, that food
would have suffice you all. It
would have been sufficient.
Why? Because, by him,
intentionally, not saying
bismillah, the barak that Allah
would generally place on the
food was was revoked. However,
had he said bismillah and began
with bismillah, the would have
been placed into that food. We
live in a time of
superficiality where everything
that matters is size and
number, right? It's gotta be
the biggest. If it's not super
big, it's not important and
it's gotta be the most and if
it's not the most, it's not
important, right? This is how
we judge our environment now.
It's all about the most numbers
and the biggest crowds and
right? How many followers I
have? Don't worry about the
quality of those numbers. All
we worry about is the number.
However, the same thing goes
with issues of wealth, money.
We only look at how much I have
and how much I make but how
much of it is actually blessed
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
That is what is important. What
makes wealth and food and
health and so forth. Something
that is worthy and worthwhile
and qualitative is that Allah
blesses it. If Allah has not
blessed it, it doesn't matter
how much it is. Even if it
appears to be more, it's
actually less. Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala,
Allah does stunt He does stunt
Usury and he increases charity.
What does that mean? When a
person takes interest, they've
essentially made one dollar
into two. It's a very simple to
simplify it. They've
essentially made one dollar
into two. You would think that
a person who takes Ribba is
always winning. But really he's
always losing. Even if he has a
higher number, the in that
money is not going to be there
and you can see that. I mean,
there's people swimming in
wealth taken by way of Riba and
they it goes and comes as fast
as you know, it goes as fast as
it comes. There's no quality to
it. Person can't really can't
really catch it, can't capture
it because there's no in it and
the same thing goes with time.
and so, the issue is not the
number. The issue is what? The
issue is whether Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has placed
in it or not. It's mentioned
this issue of Barakah Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions this, the prophet
mentions this in a narration.
He says
He says,
were in
[Silence]
un untruthful
then the the blessing of that
transaction will be will be
stunted, will be taken, will be
revoked. And so, let's say a
person has a a car, right? If I
tell the buyer, if I, let's say
I have a car and I tell the
buyer, hey, this car has a
problem with the transmission.
What's going to happen to the
price of that car? It's
going to go right? But the
prophet promises us that if you
are transparent and honest,
even though the price is less,
you will receive more in way of
blessing from Allah. That
wealth will be qualitative.
However, if I conceal that
problem, I conceal that
problem. The price of that
vehicle goes up, right? And I
will get more. It appears to be
more but really it is. It is
So, the issue of Barakah is
very important. We have to seek
quality, not necessarily
quantity. Quantity is only
important when it is
qualitative. If it is, if it is
lacking in quality, quantity
will not necessarily amend
that. So,
this is an important point
that Ibn Al Kaim Rahim Allah
makes here. It's a point that
is alluded to throughout the
Quran and Sunnah. It's
important that an individual
understand that just because
something appears to be more
doesn't necessarily mean that
it is. Just because something
appears to be less doesn't
necessarily mean that it is.
And this is what we are taught
in the Quran that no minority
is mentioned in the Quran
except that it is praised. And
no major is mentioned in the
Quran except that it is
dispraised. This is not to say
that a majority cannot be
praiseworthy but it is to say
that quality is always more
important than quantity. It's
enough for tonight. Inshallah,
we'll continue next week with
[Arabic recitation]